Lucia:我用一下剪刀
Lucia: I'll use the scissors.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia:先把这个形状画出来嗯底下那个
Lucia: First, I'll draw out this shape, the one at the bottom.
Jake:换了个脸型
Jake: Changed the face shape.
Jake:整容大整容
Jake: Major cosmetic surgery.
Lucia:对然后我从后面再画五官
Lucia: Yeah, and then I'll draw the facial features from the back.
Lucia:但我觉得现在这个反正定位还行
Lucia: But I think this positioning is fine for now.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia:好所以我先剪下来试试
Lucia: Okay, so I'll cut it out first to try.
Lucia:但是其实我最开始的那个它才是
Lucia: But actually, my original one was...
Lucia:它才是合比例的大小
Lucia: It was the correct proportional size.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:所以我现在有点虚
Lucia: So I'm feeling a bit weak right now.
Lucia:没事还可以再画一点对
Lucia: It's okay, we can draw a bit more, right?
Jake:最不缺板
Jake: There's no shortage of boards.
Lucia:希望这个定位是准的
Lucia: I hope this positioning is accurate.
Lucia:然后再在上面
Lucia: Then on top of that...
Lucia:我在我就可以用白板笔了嗯
Lucia: I can use the whiteboard marker, yeah.
Lucia:要不然的话还得
Lucia: Otherwise, I still need to...
Lucia:呃我稍等一下啊
Lucia: Uh, wait a moment.
Lucia:我想把这个先解开
Lucia: I want to undo this first.
Lucia:看看他的大小和定位符合不
Lucia: Let's see if the size and positioning match.
Lucia:符合的话这个稿子就可以投入生产了
Lucia: If they match, then this draft can go into production.
Lucia:好像小了一点
Lucia: It seems a bit small.
Lucia:以这一半大小来说
Lucia: In terms of half this size.
Tasha:除了通这个别的我都完成了
Tasha: I've finished everything except this one.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha:我说除了通这个水之外别的我都干了
Tasha: I mean, aside from this water task, I've done everything else.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:要吃吗
Tasha: Want to eat?
Lucia:嗯 可以吃了吗
Lucia: Hmm, can we eat now?
Lucia:稍稍等我等会把这弄完
Lucia: Wait a bit, I'll finish this first.
Lucia:洗个手谢谢微微
Lucia: Let me wash my hands, thank you, Tasha.
Tasha:那我就要放到这里了
Tasha: Then I'll just leave it here.
Jake:薇薇做狗吗
Jake: Tasha, are you a dog?
Tasha:不做
Tasha: No.
Jake:不做狗
Jake: Not a dog?
Jake:我就两条看门狗
Jake: I only have two watchdogs.
Jake:哈哈哈刚刚好
Jake: Haha, just perfect.
Tasha:哦靠
Tasha: Oh, come on.
Jake:就 是吗
Jake: Right?
Tasha:太过份了
Tasha: That's too much.
Jake:就是别人家里面是俩石狮子
Jake: Other people have two stone lions at home.
Jake:咱俩看门狗
Jake: We have two watchdogs.
Lucia:果然在我把它修成这个大小之后
Lucia: Sure enough, after I cut it to this size...
Lucia:他可能稍微有点点小
Lucia: It might be a bit small.
Jake:这是什么品种
Jake: What breed is this?
Lucia:管他什么品种
Lucia: Who cares about the breed.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:我已经放弃专门搞一个品种出来了
Lucia: I've given up on specifically breeding one type.
Lucia:好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia:因为你要画的很那什么的话
Lucia: Because if you want to draw it very specifically...
Lucia:我得用铅笔弄个稿
Lucia: I need to draft this with a pencil.
Lucia:嗯要不然用更小一点的
Lucia: Hmm, maybe use a smaller one.
Lucia:更小一点的盒子看一下怎么样
Lucia: Let's try a smaller box.
Tasha:你干嘛要拿这个纸
Tasha: Why are you taking this paper?
Jake:拿这个纸擦一下
Jake: To wipe something.
Lucia:那个不行
Lucia: That won't work.
Tasha:宠物宠物殡葬师
Tasha: Pet funeral director.
Lucia:身体把这个字都翻到里面更好
Lucia: It'd be better if the body turned this word inside.
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But...
Lucia:我觉得我已经懒得翻了
Lucia: I think I'm too lazy to do it.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it.
Alice:用完了吗
Alice: Are you done with it?
Lucia:啊你用吧
Lucia: Ah, you can use it.
Alice:白板笔
Alice: The whiteboard marker.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 先这样
Lucia: Let's do this first.
Lucia: 看看背面这个定位现在行不行
Lucia: Let's see if the positioning on the back is okay.
Lucia: 定位行我就投影到正面去
Lucia: If it's good, I'll project it to the front.
Lucia:这最好下来一点
Lucia: This should go down a bit.
Lucia:其它的基本上可以了
Lucia: The rest is basically fine.
Lucia:但是我不敢上面上直接
Lucia: But I don't dare to go directly on top.
Lucia:我去
Lucia: Oh my.
Lucia:好像
Lucia: It seems...
Lucia:可以
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia:那就在画一个
Lucia: Then let's draw another one.
Jake: 我可算想起来刮胡子了啊
Jake: I finally remembered to shave.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 我可算想起来了
Jake: I finally remembered.
Tasha: 想起来什么
Tasha: Remembered what?
Jake: 把胡子刮了
Jake: To shave my beard.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 等会就有最需要你的活了啊
Tasha: There's a task that needs you the most later.
Jake: 什么搅和
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 打蛋液
Jake: Beating eggs?
Jake: 打奶油
Jake: Whipping cream?
Tasha: 拉拉面团
Tasha: Kneading dough.
Jake: 拉面
Jake: Noodles.
Jake: 我们要干嘛
Jake: What are we doing?
Tasha: 你觉得有意思就好
Tasha: As long as you find it fun.
Jake: 我们要
Jake: We need to...
Jake: 小贝
Jake: Xiaobei
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Jake: 肉松小贝
Jake: Floss roll cake
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Jake:面团是干嘛的呀
Jake: What's the dough for?
Tasha:做麻薯用的
Tasha: For making mochi
Jake:做麻薯
Jake: Making mochi
Tasha:肉公小贝还做吗今天
Tasha: Are we still making the meat floss roll cake today?
Tasha:我在问你
Tasha: I'm asking you
Tasha:我不是在
Tasha: I'm not
Jake:呃 我们要 嗯马暑是要当独的
Jake: Uh, we need... um, mochi is separate
Tasha:甜品
Tasha: Dessert
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Jake:可以做呀
Jake: We can make it
Jake:做吧
Jake: Let's do it
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:怎么十分不愿意的感觉
Jake: Why do you seem so reluctant?
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no
Tasha: 一切听您的指挥
Tasha: I'm following your lead
Tasha: 加20克黄油
Tasha: Add 20 grams of butter
Tasha: 切20克出来
Tasha: Cut out 20 grams
Jake: 开
Jake: Start
Lucia:ok and
Lucia: Okay and
Lucia:不行 这样加不自然
Lucia: No, it doesn't look natural like this
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 啊你还在用剪刀那我等一会
Lucia: Ah, you're still using the scissors, I'll wait
Lucia: 我记得好像还有一把不过那把剪刀就是
Lucia: I remember there's another pair, but that one's
Lucia: 就是 劲比较小
Lucia: Well, it's not as sharp
Lucia: 如果它还在这的话
Lucia: If it's still here
Lucia:哇 yes
Lucia: Wow, yes
Alice:把狗的脚剪短了
Alice: Trim the dog's nails
Lucia:是大家轮流唱一首歌吗
Lucia: Are we all taking turns to sing a song?
Lucia: 还是大家合唱一首歌
Lucia: Or are we singing a song together?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Either way
Katrina: 合唱很那个
Katrina: Group singing is
Lucia: solo
Lucia: Solo
Katrina: 有没有感觉大家都淡淡的
Katrina: Doesn't it feel like everyone is a bit indifferent?
Katrina: 不是很想的激情的感觉
Katrina: Not really enthusiastic
Katrina: 主要是这样还主要是衣服还没租对吗
Katrina: Mainly because we haven't rented the costumes yet, right?
Tasha: 嗯还好还没走
Tasha: Hmm, good thing you haven't left yet.
Katrina: 没事我们是因为没租才做的决定的
Katrina: It's alright, we made the decision because we couldn't rent.
Tasha: 其实租的话也可
Tasha: Actually, renting is okay too.
Tasha: 现在租也来得及
Tasha: We can still rent now.
Lucia: 主要这几天大家排的话
Lucia: The main thing is, these days if everyone lines up...
Lucia: 一个不知道人齐不齐
Lucia: We don't know if everyone will be here.
Katrina: 嗯 人也不一定
Katrina: Yeah, not everyone might be.
Katrina: 然后第二感觉时间上
Katrina: And secondly, the timing feels...
Lucia: 对然后感觉时间上有点紧张
Lucia: Yeah, the timing feels a bit tight.
Shure:  这真的是happy metal吗
Shure: Is this really happy metal?
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Katrina: 我觉得可以剪成综艺了
Katrina: I think it can be edited into a variety show.
Katrina: 我们有自已的歌
Katrina: We have our own songs.
Lucia:这
Lucia: This...
Lucia:太难剪了
Lucia: It's too hard to edit.
Lucia:你还用白板笔吗
Lucia: Are you still using the whiteboard marker?
Lucia:你先用
Lucia: You use it first.
Shure:  你们在做狗
Shure: Are you guys making a dog?
Shure:  哎对
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure:  很棒
Shure: Awesome.
Shure:  有点东西只能说
Shure: I can only say it's something.
Shure:  我靠好香啊
Shure: Wow, it smells so good.
Shure:  还有烤地瓜
Shure: And there's roasted sweet potato.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 烤了你吃吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat it if it's roasted?
Shure:  我草
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 繁荣这经济繁荣
Jake: Boosting the economy, boosting the economy.
Jake: 局部经济繁荣
Jake: Local economic boom.
Lucia:完了
Lucia: It's over.
Shure:  烤糊了
Shure: It's burnt.
Tasha: 我刚刚感觉不够熟
Tasha: I just felt it wasn't cooked enough.
Tasha: 又烤了一会
Tasha: So I roasted it a bit longer.
Tasha: 你要不拿出去吃
Tasha: Why don't you take it out to eat?
Lucia:行
Lucia: Okay.
Shure:  来张纸来张纸
Shure: Give me a piece of paper, give me a piece of paper.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Tasha: 这个这个盒子放上面了
Tasha: This, this box, put it on top.
Lucia:用一下白板笔
Lucia: Using the whiteboard marker for a moment.
Jake: 我吃一个
Jake: I'll have one.
Jake: 可以吃吗
Jake: Can I eat it?
Jake: 应该可以
Jake: It should be fine.
Shure:  好香啊我靠
Shure: Smells so good, damn.
Shure:  这皮他是不能吃
Shure: You can't eat the skin.
Shure:  他酥了
Shure: It's crispy.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure:  我说这皮都能吃
Shure: I said you can eat the skin.
Shure:  感觉
Shure: Feels like it.
Tasha: 是啊煮过了
Tasha: Yeah, it's cooked.
杨老板 我靠
Jake: Damn.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake:绝香
Jake: Smells amazing.
Shure:  巨香
Shure: Super fragrant.
Shure:  我第一次
Shure: This is my first time...
Alice:你烧的就是专门的这种可以弄的
Alice: What you cooked is specifically for this.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 干
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干一个
Shure: Cheers.
Shure:  干地瓜
Shure: Dried sweet potato.
Jake: 地瓜会自动翻译
Jake: Sweet potato will translate automatically.
Shure:  直接给我翻译成什么
Shure: What does it translate to?
Jake:：groundmelon
Jake: Groundmelon.
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha.
Alice:我靠 来点
Alice: Damn, give me some.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 来重金属摇滚
Jake: Let's play some heavy metal rock.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:有声
Jake: Got sound.
Jake:这不对呀这不对呀
Jake: This isn't right, this isn't right.
Jake: 是不是听不懂中文啊
Jake: Can't understand Chinese, huh?
Jake: 哇只会pop吧
Jake: Wow, only knows pop, huh?
Shure:  好pop呀
Shure: So pop.
Shure:  no style more her heavy metal
Shure: No style, more like her heavy metal.
Jake: 谢彬竹玩嗨了
Jake: Xie Binzhu is having a blast.
Jake: 第一回玩吗
Jake: First time playing?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 他还弹过钢琴
Jake: He also played the piano.
Shure:  啊弹钢琴还不错
Shure: Oh, playing piano is not bad.
Shure:  我靠还给他化妆
Shure: Damn, even put makeup on him.
Jake: 是是挺是挺可爱哎呦
Jake: Yeah, quite cute, oh my.
Alice:OK 了
Alice: Okay, done.
Alice:好小狗 over
Alice: Good puppy, over
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 我专门睁大眼睛
Jake: I'm deliberately widening my eyes
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake: 还有大眼睛
Jake: And big eyes too
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 所以就使用那个表情
Lucia: So just use that expression
Lucia: 表情包模式
Lucia: Expression pack mode
Jake: 他不会
Jake: He can't do it
Jake: 你得给他歌词
Jake: You need to give him the lyrics
Tasha: 杨老师最需要你的时候来了
Tasha: Jake, this is when we need you the most
Tasha: 好了你可以把地瓜放下了
Tasha: Alright, you can put the sweet potato down now
Jake: 我杵哪了
Jake: Where am I standing?
Lucia:这是啊这个这个东西
Lucia: Here, this thing
Jake: 我杵这了
Jake: I'm standing here
Shure:  他们说有可能是
Shure: They said it might be
Shure:  这是一个引子啊
Shure: This is a lead-in
Tasha: 你带吧我手上有水
Tasha: You carry it, my hands are wet
Shure:  有可能是个引子哦
Shure: It might be a lead-in
Jake: 一个引子
Jake: A lead-in
Shure:  让AI写我是草履虫和我
Shure: Let AI write "I am a paramecium and me"
Jake: 就是大伙可以给词他他词写的不行
Jake: Everyone can give him lyrics, his writing isn't good
Jake: 如果觉得你觉得怎么样
Jake: If you think, what do you think?
Shure:  还行
Shure: It's okay
Jake:确实还行
Jake: It's actually okay
Shure:  很含糊哇哈哈哈这个节奏
Shure: It's very vague, hahaha, this rhythm
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over
Jake: 人机大战
Jake: Man vs. machine battle
Shure: 我败下一程居然
Shure: I actually lost one round
Katrina:  好看
Katrina: Looks good
Alice: 第一
Alice: First place
Tasha:第一
Tasha: First place
Shure: 巨好吃
Shure: Super tasty
Alice:完了 剪不动
Alice: It's over, can't cut
Jake: 我要干什么
Jake: What am I supposed to do
Jake: 啊我要搅和吗
Jake: Ah, should I mix it?
Tasha: 把它们揉在一起
Tasha: Knead them together
Lucia:呃
Lucia: Uh
Jake: 哎呦这
Jake: Oh no, this
Lucia: 这边出标了
Lucia: There's a sign here
Jake: 哎呦好烫啊
Jake: Ouch, it's so hot.
Tasha: 这还烫啊
Tasha: This is hot?
Tasha: 已经凉了好久了
Tasha: It's been cooling for a while now.
Shure:  我输给AI了我靠
Shure: I lost to AI, damn it.
Nicous: 为什么
Nicous: Why?
Shure:  确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈但是没有记忆点
Jake: Hahaha, but there's no memorable point.
Jake: 我觉得对
Jake: I think so.
Jake: AI他这没
Jake: AI doesn't have that.
Jake: 哎呀我靠好烫啊
Jake: Oh my, damn, it's hot.
Katrina: 朗朗上口
Katrina: It's catchy.
Tasha: 不好意思要不你脱下来吧
Tasha: Sorry, maybe you should take it off.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 我以为已经过了好久了
Tasha: I thought it had been a long time already.
Tasha: 那那等会你再来搅
Tasha: Then, you can stir it later.
Shure:  这就非常草东味你知道吗
Shure: This has a very Caodong flavor, you know?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 就是那个中间那个嘣嘣嘣嘣
Shure: It's like that middle part, boom boom boom.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:啊好烫啊
Jake: Ah, it's so hot.
Shure:  你可以拿这个
Shure: You can use this.
Jake:哎呀你看一下手机怎么回事
Jake: Oh, check the phone, what's going on?
Shure:  我刚刚那个纸杯
Shure: That paper cup just now.
Shure:  那个多久 挤不挤
Shure: How long, is it crowded?
Jake:没空间了是吧
Jake: No space, right?
Jake: 呃不算挤
Jake: Uh, not crowded.
Jake: 不挤不挤
Jake: Not crowded, not crowded.
Tasha: 我都走路上了吗
Tasha: Am I already on the road?
Alice: 应该怎么最后没有
Alice: Should I, but in the end, no.
Tasha: 吃吗
Tasha: Eat?
Jake: 啊也没有interaction
Jake: Ah, no interaction either.
Tasha:最后一个
Tasha: The last one.
Shure:  对这个间奏还不错
Shure: Yes, this interlude is pretty good.
Jake: 没关系拿过来直接用
Jake: It's okay, just bring it over and use it directly.
Shure:  这才是happy metal
Shure: This is real happy metal.
Shure:  但这这没词
Shure: But, it doesn't have lyrics.
Jake: 没词
Jake: No lyrics.
Jake: 他这写词很沙雕的
Jake: His lyrics are really silly.
Tasha:我还要不要在报备
Tasha: Should I still report this?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我看一下他是是没空间了还是什么
Jake: Let me check if he's out of space or something.
Alice: 应该录了有快3个小时了
Alice: We should have been recording for almost 3 hours.
Lucia:哎我的还在亮着吗
Lucia: Hey, is mine still on?
Alice: 我做小狗之前还有40多个G
Alice: I had over 40GB left before I made the dog.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 啥意思呢
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我刷一下刷
Jake: Let me refresh it.
Jake: 这个是我从那个
Jake: This is from that...
Jake: 我同学把把那个
Jake: My classmate copied that...
Jake: 把那个他的Wei page直接copy过来
Jake: Copied his Wei page directly over.
Jake: 就给写了一个
Jake: And wrote one.
Shure:  这个才对
Shure: This is correct.
Shure:  你刚刚旺仔中间加个分号了
Shure: You added a semicolon in the middle of Wangzai.
Shure:  加个分号才才能
Shure: Adding a semicolon will...
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  就是识别下一个
Shure: It helps recognize the next one.
Jake: 哎是没录吗
Jake: Hey, is it not recording?
Alice: 录了因为我在
Alice: It's recording because I...
Alice: 做小狗之前
Alice: Before making the dog...
Alice:我之前还有只有40多个g
Alice: I still had over 40GB left before.
Jake:那好奇怪
Jake: That's so strange.
Lucia: 随便录一个
Lucia: Just record anything.
Katrina: 最后还半个小时
Katrina: There's only half an hour left.
Jake: 我我我试一下我试一下试一下
Jake: Let me try, let me try.
Jake: 什什么情况
Jake: What's going on?
Jake: 什么情况
Jake: What's happening?
Jake: 笑什么
Jake: Why are you laughing?
Shure: 认识江苏的
Shure: Do you know people from Jiangsu?
Jake: 我也江苏人
Jake: I'm also from Jiangsu.
Jake: 但是我是很我
Jake: But back then, I...
Jake: 我那时候还是病题作文
Jake: I used to write essay prompts.
Jake: 我我那时候还命题作文
Jake: I used to write essay prompts back then.
Shure:  他没有
Shure: He didn't...
Shure:  没有
Shure: No, he didn't.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  哦你们只选两科
Shure: Oh, you guys only chose two subjects.
Jake: 对当初就是我
Jake: Yes, back then I...
Tasha:我我
Tasha: I, I...
Tasha: 我也是巫师
Tasha: I was also a wizard.
Katrina: 我生物当时
Katrina: I took biology at that time.
Katrina: 五个选择题四四个不确定那个定哪一家
Katrina: For the five multiple-choice questions, I'm unsure about four of them. Which one should I choose?
Katrina: 但A+没什么用只有省内的有用
Katrina: But an A+ isn't useful, it's only useful within the province.
Katrina: 但是他昨文是什么就是嗯
Katrina: But what did he write yesterday, like, um
Katrina: 你觉得晚上
Katrina: Do you think in the evening
Katrina: 就是我们一般是
Katrina: We generally
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina: 如果你一直看他一直给你推这个
Katrina: If you keep watching, he keeps pushing this to you.
Katrina: 但是他那个很明显就是这个
Katrina: But it's very obvious that this
Katrina: 出题人是支持这个现象的
Katrina: The question setter supports this phenomenon.
Katrina: 但是大家可以通过这种推荐的
Katrina: But everyone can use these recommendations.
Katrina: 13还是可以就是交到志周到合的朋友
Katrina: And still make friends with similar interests.
Katrina: 但是我的关健词完全相同
Katrina: But my keywords are exactly the same.
Katrina: 只有半个小时
Katrina: Only half an hour left.
Katrina: 1字未动写了一偏小说
Katrina: Without writing a single word, I wrote a novel.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 最后语文高考
Shure: In the end, the Chinese high school exam.
Shure:  我奔着北欧来的
Shure: I came for Northern Europe.
Shure:  闹呢
Shure: Are you kidding?
Shure:  我钱夹里当时放了两张照片
Shure: At that time, I had two photos in my wallet.
Shure:  一张老番茄一张何同学
Shure: One of an old tomato, one of a classmate.
Shure:  差太多了
Shure: The difference was huge.
Shure:  人家他妈是复旦
Shure: His mom went to Fudan University.
Katrina: 你们那个北邮分是不是比985高
Katrina: Is your Beiyou score higher than 985?
Shure:  比比好多985分高
Shure: Higher than many 985 scores.
Katrina: 那你有没有后悔
Katrina: Do you regret it?
Shure:  不后悔
Shure: No regrets.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:唉
Lucia: Sigh.
Shure:  我无所谓
Shure: I don't care.
Katrina: 你报志愿的时候
Katrina: When you were filling out your application
Tasha: 套盒误差
Tasha: Packaging error
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 能录吧这个啊
Jake: Can we record this?
Jake: 能录吧哈哈哈
Jake: Can we record this? Hahaha
Jake: 没有
Jake: No
Jake: 这一下午都没有
Jake: Not the whole afternoon
Jake: 应该是不知道为什么可能是崩掉了
Jake: Maybe it crashed for some reason.
Jake: 没关系吧
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 可以你对你可以对没关系
Jake: It's fine, you can, it's okay.
Alice:专对小狗录像了
Alice: Specifically recording the puppy.
Shure:  奖金
Shure: Prize money
Jake: 来来写一首特朗普之歌
Jake: Come on, write a song about Trump
Shure:  别别别
Shure: No, no, no
Shure:  哎我们来命题作文battle吧
Shure: Hey, let's do a themed essay battle
Shure:  大家随便出个题
Shure: Everyone throw out a topic
Shure:  然后让他写和让我写
Shure: Then let him write and I'll write
Shure:  看看哪个更牛逼
Shure: See which one is cooler
Jake: 那出个题
Jake: Then throw out a topic
Shure:  来出个题
Shure: Come on, throw out a topic
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Okay
Shure:  就随便说
Shure: Just say anything
Jake:谢彬竹之歌吧
Jake: A song about Xie Binzhu
Jake: 要不就哈哈哈
Jake: Or just hahaha
Shure:  他不AI不知道谢彬竹是什么东西
Shure: He doesn't know what Xie Binzhu is
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay
Jake: 我也给他形容一下
Jake: I'll describe it to him
Jake: 谢彬竹是一个什么什么什么啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu is a what what what
Nicous: 谢彬竹是一个被吃掉会主动说谢谢的人
Nicous: Xie Binzhu is someone who says thank you when being eaten
Nicous: 被吃一口就会主动说谢谢的人
Nicous: When you take a bite, they say thank you
Jake: 你你这像是叫什么
Jake: You, you sound like those old TV shows about top scholars
Jake: 以前考状元的那种电视
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Shure:  我们这样
Shure: Let's do this
Shure:  随便拿个什么物品之类的当命题
Shure: Just pick any random object as the theme
Jake: 好也可以
Jake: Okay, that works too
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Jake:北冰洋吧
Jake: Beibingyang then
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Beibingyang
Jake: 北冰北冰洋
Jake: Beibing, Beibingyang
Jake: 北冰洋的什么
Jake: Beibingyang's what
Jake: 唇唇膏
Jake: Lip balm
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Beibingyang's panda
Jake: 北冰洋的熊猫
Jake: Beibingyang's panda
Jake: DK音乐
Jake: DK music
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Shure: 北冰洋的熊猫是吗
Shure: Beibingyang's panda, right?
Jake: style
Jake: Style
Shure: style你随便
Shure: Style, you decide
Jake:我我随便
Jake: I'll just go with it
Lucia: 好了嗯
Lucia: Alright, um
Jake: 哦我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这个肚子是不是该给它减掉呢
Lucia: Should we get rid of this belly?
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 喂哎呦我去啊
Jake: Hello, oh my god.
Jake: 你好呵呵你好你好
Jake: Hello, hi, hello, hi.
Jake: 来了来了来了来了
Jake: Coming, coming, coming.
Shure:  哎帮帮把把把着一下扶一下
Shure: Hey, help hold this for a bit.
Jake: 帮我帮我敲敲吧啊
Jake: Help me, knock it for me.
Shure:  你别让他happy metal就泡吧就好了
Shure: Don't let him get into happy metal, just hang out.
Shure:  你或者你不指定style你直接就是
Shure: Or if you don't specify a style, just go with it.
Lucia: 哇好可爱你这腮红好心动啊
Lucia: Wow, so cute, your blush is adorable.
Shure:  不用他他会自动也也也生成一个style
Shure: No need, it'll automatically generate a style.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 套装误拆
Lucia: Oops, wrong outfit.
Lucia: 我还给他剪了个尾巴
Lucia: I also cut a tail for it.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 要不走上去
Jake: Should we go up?
Jake: 帮我拿一下吧
Jake: Help me grab that.
Jake: 来谢谢你啊
Jake: Thanks a lot.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake: 上来吃饭吧
Jake: Come up and eat.
Jake: 什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina: 北冰洋的熊猫
Katrina: Polar Bear of the Arctic.
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Polar Bear of the Arctic.
Jake: 有词吗在这是吧
Jake: Does it have lyrics? Here, right?
Jake: 不是这个
Jake: Not this one.
Jake: 我我以前喜欢给他写的
Jake: I used to like writing for him.
Jake: 就是直接给他style OP
Jake: Just directly give him a style OP.
Jake: 对就是animation OP啊
Jake: Yeah, like an animation OP.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Jake: 就感觉北朝与战士的那种那种东西
Jake: Just feels like the stuff from Northern Korea and warriors.
Jake: 永不什么
Jake: Never what?
Shure:  永不窒息
Shure: Never suffocate.
Jake: 永不窒息
Jake: Never suffocate.
Jake: 大熊猫永不窒息
Jake: Giant panda never suffocates.
Jake: 嗯他默认应该都是流星
Jake: Yeah, it's usually default to a meteor.
Lucia: 好诡异啊
Lucia: So weird.
Shure:  我不能受他牵连
Shure: I can't get involved with him.
Katrina: 我要构思我自己
Katrina: I need to come up with my own.
Jake: 上吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake: 走上去吃饭吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs for lunch.
Lucia:好啦
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 上去配个乐吧要不就
Jake: How about we add some music upstairs?
Jake: 饭店驻唱
Jake: Singing in the restaurant.
Jake: 哈哈哈那李先生
Jake: Hahaha, Mr. Li.
Jake: 李先生面馆
Jake: Mr. Li's noodle shop.
Shure: 前面得给我立个二维码
Shure: Put a QR code in front for me.
Shure:  好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, hahaha.
Jake: 李先生面馆驻唱
Jake: Singing at Mr. Li's noodle shop.
Jake: 首席驻唱
Jake: The lead singer.
Lucia: 熊猫的
Lucia: The panda one.
Alice: 不知道
Alice: 我买的是桂花了
Alice: I bought the osmanthus one.
Shure:  这个反正是一人一份
Shure: Anyway, everyone gets one.
Tasha:这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Katrina: 白茶
Katrina: White tea.
Lucia:怎么感觉还是有点
Lucia: Why does it still feel a bit...
Lucia:算了
Lucia: Forget it.
Shure:  这个是吗
Shure: Is this it?
Nicous: 要不然他整了这么多配菜
Nicous: Otherwise, why did he prepare so many side dishes?
Shure:  我不知道反正是咚不咚
Shure: I don't know, anyway, it's "dong dong."
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  咚不咚咚咚
Shure: "Dong dong dong dong."
Lucia: 放哪了
Lucia: Where did you put it?
Nicous: 杨老板这架子不是我们的对不对
Nicous: Jake, this shelf isn't ours, right?
Jake: 什么意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我操哈哈哈
Jake: Damn, hahaha.
Jake: 你服了我操
Jake: You got me, damn.
Shure:  臭二次元滚出去
Shure: Smelly otaku, get out.
Shure: 好恶心呀
Shure: So disgusting.
Jake: 哼这不行了
Jake: Hmph, this won't do.
Jake: 来一个
Jake: Come on.
Jake:对不起呀
Jake: Sorry.
Nicous: 知道这个套餐里头有哪些东西吗
Nicous: Do you know what's in this set?
Jake: 考虑啊你
Jake: Think about it.
Katrina: 白切鸡和一个素藤编
Katrina: White-cut chicken and a vegetarian woven dish.
Shure:  你是不是私宅
Shure: Is this your private place?
Shure:  真恶心啊
Shure: So disgusting.
Shure:  让人坐不下
Shure: Makes it impossible to sit.
Tasha: 那我是什么
Tasha: Then what am I?
Shure:  要不我坐小孩那桌去吧
Shure: How about I sit at the kids' table?
Tasha:我是
Tasha: I am
Tasha: 海带丝和
Tasha: Seaweed and
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Beibingyang
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Beibingyang's panda
Lucia:嘿
Lucia: Hey
Lucia:这居然没餐巾纸了
Lucia: There's actually no napkins
Shure:  要加点香菜吗
Shure: Want to add some cilantro?
Lucia: 其实我可以加
Lucia: Actually, I can add it
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 他是不是没给米饭
Alice: Did he not give us rice?
Lucia: 这个米饭哦
Lucia: This rice, oh
Alice: 这是我的吗
Alice: Is this mine?
Lucia:哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh
Lucia: 我好像点的是一个面 不管了
Lucia: I think I ordered noodles, never mind
Shure:  这一生吃的最多的面
Shure: The noodles I've eaten the most in my life
Shure:  就是李先生牛肉面
Shure: are Mr. Lee's beef noodles
Shure:  你呢
Shure: How about you?